so there seems to be some confusion
online and i need to clear this up
bitcoin wasn't hacked bitcoin sv
which is a fork of bitcoin or more
specifically bitcoin cash
saw a 51 attack essentially bitcoin sv's
hash power is low
which made it cheaper to take over the
network and attack
the hash power is the amount of
computing power needed to secure the
network
and prevent against these 51 attacks but
because
not enough people see valium bsv enough
to want to mine it
the hash power is low leaving it
susceptible to an attack the more miners
the more hashing power the more secure
the network
these forks can get a little bit
complicated and i've actually broken it
down
fully in my upcoming book undressing
bitcoin so stay tuned because it's about
to launch